okay let's see if you really understand
let me give you an example okay so what
i'm trying to do here and you can see
why i mentioned to you they'll call it
perpendicular distance because that is
indeed what you are calculating right
if you have the same deal here you've
got a vector you've got two points right
can you use this idea here to work out
how far one is
from the other the application that is
cool i now have resolved my vectors in
two different directions
perpendicular to each other but this is
how the question will often be phrased
to you
can you work out a perpendicular
distance and it's then a stepping stone
to something else
so let me give you a moment my advice to
you is to draw a diagram
i'll even give you a secondary piece of
advice which is even though we're in 3d
vectors remember
back to the last term you're drawing on
a piece of paper
sometimes three dimensionality in your
diagram is actually
a what's the word i'm looking for it's a
hindrance rather than a help
it's exactly the word i was looking for
so draw a diagram what you want to seek
to make
clear is what's the relationship between
all the different things so you can draw
onto it right
i wouldn't worry too much about a 3d
coordinate system it's just where you
can place things so you can see them
okay let me give you a moment draw your
diagram
see if you can work out how you can use
the projection you're going to need to
remember how you do that with dot
products and so on and there's a few
different ways to do it
and then we'll come back together and
i'll show you my solution okay off you
go
and the first thing i want to point out
if you can have like one eye on you're
working one eye up or potentially if
you're like
i know how bad i am at multitasking just
pay attention okay
the first issue you immediately
encounter is
this question provides you three
coordinates three sets of coordinates
a b and p but
we know to work out this perpendicular
distance to resolve
this onto this particular direction here
perpendicular to a b we're going to need
to do this kind of stuff
in here right a projection of one vector
onto another
one vector onto another and i have given
you precisely no vectors
right so i've got to go from these
coordinates first to know
well what's being projected onto what
you can tell me its name right
two vectors one projected onto the other
and you understand me what's being
projected
onto it's ap right
a p that's going to get projected
onto a b a b
which i've drawn over here okay so
for starters if you want to project one
thing on to another well helps to know
what those two vectors are and the
question
doesn't state it you have to go ahead
and work that out but it's not too
difficult
to get from a to p i've got to change
the x i've got to change the y i've got
to change the z
so what do you get as your vector a p
yeah i'm gonna go from negative one to
two so that's a three
i'm gonna go from zero to one which is
one and then i'm gonna go from two to
zero
which is negative two so there's our ap
vector what about a b
yeah i'm gonna go from negative one to
one that
from zero to one which is that and then
from two to three
which is that so far so good cool so
i've got
this vector projected onto that vector
so i now begin
for my own working to say i'm projecting
a p
onto a b by the way just as a minor note
if you have a look at some of the work
examples that you can find in the
textbook or online
they will often do this thing where they
name these vectors something separate
like
u with a little squiggly or v or p or q
or a or etc there's no problem with
doing that it does make this notation
just a teeny bit more succinct i'm
trying to avoid
extrapolates flowing around especially
when one's a and then there's another a
and you just get confused so
i'm just leaving it as this because i
think you know which one's which is that
okay
now we last lesson looked at the fact
that there's a bunch of different ways
to work out
what a projection is several different
formulas i don't know which one you went
with
but the one in my head because it just
makes me laugh is the one that has
your base vector count it one two three
four times
if i recall do you remember that one uh
it looks like this you're gonna have
uh this one that comes up first it's
gonna be three
one negative two right and then
then come all of the base vectors four
times you ready
it's going to go 2 sorry 2 1 1 there
we're going to do 2 1 1 dot product
against
itself and then one last time
we multiply that entire scalar by this
dot product uh sorry this
vector does that make sense the base
vector is that okay you can use the
version which has the hats in it that's
totally fine with me
that one with the cosine in it probably
not so useful because i have no idea
what that angle is i'm just going to
leave it to one side
okay what did you get when you did the
dot product you did like
6 1 negative 2 on the numerator
4 1 and 1 on the denominator what did
you actually get when you simplified
fantastic and then this of course
is our vector right so far so good so i
have so far discovered that my diagram
is
terrible because that doesn't look like
5 6 of
my 2 1 1 vector but that's okay all it's
doing is not
i don't care about its proportions i
want to know how they're related to each
other okay
all right so far so good that's a good
start i've got this
how do i use that again to get to this
um
what what should i call it by the way
what's the name of it
i could give it a lot of different names
right i'm trying to go for a succinct
one using the language that i've got
here
for starters i'm after a distance so i'm
just going to say
absolute value magnitude of what's this
thing called
spq is that okay
now there's a bunch of different ways
that i could do it the most obvious way
that it looks like to me
is to get this i could go say from p to
a
so i'd do the opposite of this vector
and then i'd go from a to q because i
just worked out what that was
is that okay so i'm going to go ahead
and write that i reckon i can fit it
just here
p q before i strip the direction out of
it
is going to be negative ap
and then i'm going to add a q is that
all right since we're only
concerned of the distance why don't we
pythagoras
oh you want to just work out well okay i
can just do
uh a squared plus b squared equals c
squared here that's totally fine with me
if that were all we're interested in i'm
going to give you more versatile method
here which
in those times when you are not just
interested remember remember where i'm
really going
right so if i did just work out distance
cool then i have to
then work out direction right i can do
it all in one hit and very easily get
the distance out of it okay
but good pick up i know what negative ap
is
it's this but everything's backwards is
that okay so i guess i'd get
negative 3 negative 1 positive 2 is that
ok
and then i've already just determined
what this is in the previous part of my
working plus
five six of it's two on one isn't it
two one one is that all right that's
gonna be
pq okay now at this point here it just
becomes a bit of
arithmetic i'm going to give you the
answer in a second but the arithmetic is
actually not the bit that i'm worried
about
once you've put these two together to
take the absolute value take the
distance
of all of this you are going to have to
do some pythagoras just like
i mentioned before i think from memory
you're going to get an answer like this
oh let's see how good my memory is or
how bad my memory is did i get it
hooray i can do some things all right so
my stunning mental arithmetic no i just
worked it out before um
i'll show you my full working there if
you're interested if if this
computing these vectors together and
then working out your distance
was problematic for you i'll show you
the full working but the important thing
to me is you understand
the geometry of this and you'll
encounter it in
the further questions of exercise 5d
that i've assigned on the calendar
okay